so tell me go coop why do you seek even
more strength than you have already the
tournament of power opened my eyes no
way I can stay at the same level I'm at
now not fired up
that must be the guy I don't know who he
is but his Energy's absurd Rolly
[Applause]
[Music]
magnificent is amazing
looks like this is going to be tougher
than we thought yeah I can't wait
[Music]
Jenny stronger
hey everybody we got a new Dragon Ball
super movie trailer from Comic Con let's
break it down there are so many
different things going on here but we
finally get to see what the new version
of broli is going to look like Paris and
him have new backstories for the movie
so completely different
oh the old Broly movies are no longer
canon this will be the new canon so
obviously the movie is all about his
origins the origins of the sands they'll
get into the origins of the Frieza force
like the fact that they're wearing
Frieza force armor tells you a lot like
wait a minute what's going on here
during the panel they also revealed that
Goku and Vegeta will both go super
saiyan god mode which Vegeta has never
done before on the TV series before so
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
comic-con videos it's only gonna get
crazier from here so the big thing first
release date it's coming out December
2018 in Japan Funimation is doing the
North American release in January so
December for Japan January for pretty
much everybody else I'm assuming that by
the time Funimation does their release
everybody else everywhere in the world
will have gotten to see the movie too
I'm sure there'll be all kinds of more
previews that they'll release before
that December release date but obviously
I'm probably gonna have to wait till
January to watch it because I'm in the
United States so that's when my review
video would post for that but this is
crazy we got Frieza
versus Broly goku vs Broly Vigi two
forces Broly the trailer does a pretty
good job of setting up the story you
have Goku sitting there after the
tournament of power just looking to up
his power level I need to find somebody
else to fight we don't know what bro Li
and para guesses new backstory is but it
does look like it dovetails with the
origins of the sands like their planet
was destroyed they eventually became
part of the Frieza force I've already
done a video about the original Broly
backstory which now has changed but in
that original story King Vegeta found
out that he was born with a power level
of 10,000 so he's like he's gonna grow
up to kill me someday so I need to kill
him first in his own innate power as a
baby was able to protect he and Perry
cos when their planet was destroyed then
they vowed revenge but originally the
reason why he hated Goku was just
because Goku grew up next to him in
their birthing chamber and was really
loud it just pissed him off that was the
whole reason why he wanted to kill Goku
so pretty solid bet that that's one of
the things that Toriyama has changed
about the story because this
story does come for him from the movie
meaning that anything that happens is
totally canon like Broly is now canon
super saiyan god mode vegeta will be
canon these are pictures of both him and
goku with the red hair when they go into
that forum they just the different forms
that you'll see them in during the movie
so they did confirm that they would go
through multiple transformations but
that's the whole idea of this trailer I
need to unlock new levels of power when
has there been a Dragon Ball series when
Goku has not needed to unlock new levels
of power I'm assuming that he doesn't
have ultra instinct anymore because all
we see of him in the trailer is going
super saiyan then super saiyan blue and
then that's it they haven't released any
actual footage of him going super saiyan
god mode we just have this concept art
for the character designs but I think
because they're focusing so much on
introducing broglie's character like
you've never seen him before this is a
brand new character just forget about
those other movies that we did you get
to see all of broglie's different
transformations as he slowly ramps up in
his Frieza force armor to go legendary
Super Saiyan I'm also guessing that the
same with the tail at the end might be
Broly to this might be just part of his
backstory because they did the same
thing in the Legend of broli like you
got to see him as a child when he was
growing up so I think in telling his
origin story that's how they tell you
the origin of the sands so we'll see if
they've changed any aspects of how the
legendary Super Saiyans work into the
Canon of the series if they still only
appear once every thousand years if
there's some rare occurrence or if
there's some new backstory in Broly and
para guys have just been working for the
Frieza forces mercenaries in the galaxy
and there's some sort of long just
stating revenge plot that he has against
all them because if Frieza controls the
Frieza force like he came back at the
end of the tournament of power like
sorry I've been gone but I'm finally
back and it's time to take over the
universe again there might be something
that Frieza has done in the past that
would cause Broly to want to take him
down because it does look like they have
the makings of the pretty badass fight
during the movie the interesting thing
about them revisiting or
recontextualizing the origin of the
sands is as the goku already knows about
his origins is all about him not wanting
to be a weapon like the sands are
typically thought of I'm not like the
rest of my people I'm a good person but
if they're completely retelling the
origin of the sands and spending a lot
of time on that then maybe there are
things about their origins that Goku
does not know and he's going to learn
during this because otherwise they would
focus more heavily
just on broglie's origin not the actual
origin of the sands themselves I love
that whisks seems pretty excited about
this but beerus just can barely be
bothered to raise an eyebrow like okay
whatever like oh go unlock a new level
of power whatever Broly who cares but
they did say that the gods would be a
big part of this I mean they will be
going super saiyan god mode but it's
also implied that the gods themselves
are a big part of this story so it will
be fun to see if Broly comes for beerus
at some point maybe it's one of those
situations where Broly is pissed off
about the death of his planet but he
wants to take it out on the gods
themselves there still has a weird power
scaling situation she would get into
with stuff like that especially as
implied by the end of the tournament of
power like they were all just a finger
snap away from being erased if they made
the wrong choice so the gods are
powerful if Broly had any chance of
challenging any of them then this form
of legendary super saiyan will just have
to be off the charts more powerful
compared to what we've seen in the
movies before well let me know in the
comments what do you think of all this I
think the animation looks great I mean
obviously we got a taste for that with
the last big teaser they're going with a
more classical animation style so I do
love all the refreshes I'm curious to
see if they do another Dragon Ball
series that takes place after the events
of the movie if they stick with that
animation style for whatever the new
series might be but they haven't
confirmed any of that but what's gonna
happen is is because it's Comic Con week
there's so much footage that's dropping
leave all your requests in the comments
below
and obviously as we get new footage from
the Dragon Ball super movie I'll do new
Dragon Ball videos while you wait for
everything click here to rewatch that
new titans trailer and click here for
brand-new Avengers 4 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]